Tình từ cuộc kánh xác sau thông. Tình như chật từ án tòa sau thông trong 10 tích năm nay đã còn ý trình bình tích thực.
Tại nạn sau thông, giảm chim cả bá trị số, có những ngày thì con số về tỷ lệ thương vong là giảm hư bộ plưa.
Chẳng hạn như ngày húc nay ngày 1 năm tế thì giảm hư nằm mê phần chăm số người tìm mạng.
Giảm muốn mít tư phần chăm số người bị thương sau tài nạn sau thông.
Sau với nằm ngoài.
Tế ông ngày có tì lây người đi đường mì tái nạn thiệt mạng giảm mạng nhất, lấy đến hơn năm mê phần chăm.
Tìm ngày có mức giảm thấp cũng mức chiến mời phần chăm.
Cụ thè, ngày 1 chiến tháng 2 tức 1 bà tế, cả nước xảy ra muốn mới bệ vụ biệt tên nạn sau thông.
Con số này giảm, 1 hà phần chăm, sau với nằm ngoài.
Trong tắm ngày ngày bơ qua, tuần cuối ghê nhận có mạng chăm bà mê chiến vụ tên nạn sau thông.
Làm hà chăm lịch tắm người thịt mạng và hà chăm bà mê lắm người khác bị thương.
Tì lệ giảm số vụ tên nạn là hơn hà mê chiến phần chăm.
Giảm số người thêm mạng là hơn hà mê tư phần chăm và giảm số người bí thương.
Là hơn mạng mạng bà phần chăm sau với nằm ngoài.
Lửa, cái chả thông đã có những cái sự li viva.
Truyên tế, nó không có đầy là cao liệt.
Có ai vẫn là những cái ngày bí thương.
Chúng mình mũn ngày thì trong cái tế này, lửa, cái chả thông thường,
sự liệt, thường, hay nghìn, nằm chăm đến pạng,
cái trường ở bí phạm về nụ được cột.
Sự li, kinh quế, kế vi phạm, có kinh quý cơ rất đến cái tên nạn sau thông.
Nhưng là viva vê tốc độ, viva vê trải không đúng cái phần đường là đường.
Sự li đông bộ, kinh quế, kác, vê vê vê trải đoạn đoạn thông.
Kế thợ bối, kế hoạt động, khai của hả, quế thống cái bà là sự đục chí tuyến nhé.
Đã tạo được cái quà hết sức tự.
Truyên tuyên khu lòng mà là tư, mắt bò nằm.
Công ăn 2,5 tình thành.
Đã bô chỉ 1 trăm 8,5 tình trạc, trong đoạn có 6 bà tổ, kinh quát làm việc uinh tuyến tuy.
Hẹt thấu, camera, rạc, rạc, phát y mành mẹ tất dục đã làm thay đổi ý thức và mắt quá đi đường của người dân.
Với quyết tâm, tạo thái quen đã uống việc biệt không lại sẽ,
ngay từ sáng 1 mùa tế, các tổ, công tác, kinh quát bí phạm nụ được cột.
Đã được thành lập và công tác, sự li bí phạm này đã được giữ chi khép kiến thay dạm và đi bàn.
Đúng không có đáng kể vào kích quà, kéo giảm tên hậu thông trong kinh tất người đáng nó này.